hey guys I'm Lisa from the score eSports
doublelift has officially made his
return to TSM starting roster for the
2017 na LCS summer split in honor of
this we're counting down the top 10 best
plays by doublelift
throughout his career coming in at
number 10 is double is pentakill during
all starts back in 2013 they pressure of
it there's the first lap yet to stop
some bearing damage they begin to fight
the big special the Cataclysm to the
backside is right on to start up he is
reading so as in diamond right now the
first kill da da da da so as they are
still going double it with full health
in his fight as Requiem comes out he
classes in the safety and a kill on a
yellow beet here comes their guardian
angel the 1 2 3 no he misses it but he
sits back in another forum to go get in
your head yeah I'll kill for this but
one go that duffer double-bagging wow
what a way to get it pace at the end of
a 48 minute game looks like North
America is its cruising down furthest
exit grabbing the ninth spot on our list
it's double its 3v1 triple kill Ellucian
against immortals during this 2016 na
LCS summer split event is also getting
low but they might be able to find it
out double lip gets one can he make it
to Hootie now the next Tigers are coming
at us that is all in their doll it's
going to go crazy the wandering through
solo
get themself the triple I guess that's
what they're doing pick up a triple on
your lucious and double lift comes up
huge
keeping CSM right in there taking the
eighth spot is double of game winning
pentakill on CLG while in c9 space after
ripping his finger during a basketball
incident this play went down in history
as a nine-fingered Penta flash it again
for me do to try and set up the team
falls goes down before being able to put
out anything a possible pentakill here
for double if that's a triple video siz
clothes
chronobreak cracked right in favorite
quadrants there it is
a few more kills for doublelift on ask
is it the last job you gotta let kids up
peg DuckTales shutting down sneaky
and they shut down cloud I'd take home
the victory broken finger ripped torn
apart take a few off his hand he's still
going to come out strong and go crazy
don't let going ham Douglas getting the
practical STL G takes down cloud nine
doublelift is amazing at tithing on vein
and in our number seven play he proves
it against team iron get it really easy
I like that all by hot shot you really
deterring everything right as soon as
the roof prism wears off he goes face
first like a bath towel atomic quite a
pop of this right think that is a huge
focus here he goes down mega zero on the
run catch up a lip right there it's just
way too much house Quicksilver pinned a
barrier into everything he has he's on
his knees praying right now to get out
of this one it may actually work he gets
a good doesn't clicking in the field
tumble again double it this way amazing
he kicked it one more time let's wiggle
guildford double if the mechanics are
amazing double is pentakill on Sivir
against immortals during the 2016 summer
split comes in 6 on our list
Nicole Beltre and the ash arrow with all
these cleanses coming out that scare on
the front line reignover what if it was
a scout doesn't do much they may be able
to get hotter Drona shift goes down
monster will be coming back up and it
looks like they keep going for the pike
awnser throws back hooni goes down now
it's going to be on a wild turtle they
try to get any flat for fire that's
going to be the hand wild turtles
getting the record states now there's
double it's rather I should say and it's
the triple kill going forward in the
fight pen they kept down that can hang
ahead the path name is nod do they turn
around for the kill
sponsor fighting a minion opus out
[Applause]
the most petty kills in LCS history for
double if and also even closer to a
thousand still in a climactic moment to
potentially 200 immortal
grabbing the fifth spot on our list is
SS incredible mechanics on vain in this
to be one vs. team Vulcan higher here
for Vulcan because they have re with
already a death fire granted double up
in trouble two members more than he
expected just dives right on it oh I
wish I don't goes in on psycho ticket
snuck back this could be the kill for
double he gets one uni life steal blood
water it's going to be close you know
why I do god so believed double kill
coming in at number four is double its
pentakill against PSW Aries putting all
opponents in their dreams over the wall
happy our campuses oh they're going in
autopsy be almost immediately pump
positive damage coming down to the rifle
they pry the whole thing to get everyone
away from him it's just going to delay
the inevitable
what boy boy are they live in the Des
Moines Hot Shot both live is no
[Applause]
[Applause]
stealing the third spot it's double
lifts 1v1 outplay against teen Lauren
mega zero
HomeGuard got he does have home guard
boots he's running on in Dublin leaves
at and runs the heck away from the turbo
rocket boots mega zero he puts the slow
down can he win this duel gets knocked
up into the air still trying to run mega
pop salty it's going to be the south in
from Dublin who he Jukes it will Megan
got you going back for the [ __ ] I was
going to be enough for devil if the
posterior gets one shot in there the
wind / so it's not going to be enough
doublet get the duel coming in second on
our list is doublelift insane pentakill
on CLG against TSN after multiple
members of CLG get deleted double it
turns the fight around it stops it looks
like it'd have to be a flash initiation
from either Alistar or just a nice quick
by Nautilus they get X 50 into charge
let's see if they go for broke kick
Smitty takes a lot of damage that could
be the ah so a lateral that they're
going to wait on it less boy hits up
Zion smarter and they're also waiting
for mini gnar now he gets an ultimate
not against the wall TSM actually blows
the few summoners to get to the right
position to be in the right spot Zach
Hill going to them but dyrus has also
fallen that's going to be pulled out
they're going down way too close now for
CLG triple kill for turtle who's looking
for the Quadra not going to get it that
time
it's a triple for double if he's like
okay but nowhere and it looks like the
fight was going to turn a DSM size but
double if the whole tie was free hitting
that's might be the game stealing the
number one spot on our list is
doublelift famous game changing team
fight against c9 during this 2016 summer
finals the front line here comes Rudy
Goldman occupé my captain yes they do
file Frost is down losing to the train
of life as well though four versus four
no supports alive no guardian angels
Remedios whereas TSM still have two in
two years wall we resolve sub couple now
can they have the follow-up damage a
couple cells come in they've got the
extent and they shut up down to sixteen
hundred damage fringes can okay no below
me do sort of anaka traces - another
look at your da definitely all guilty
saf3 if that goes down at age 4 TSM SS
guards around the fight staying alive so
much bacon 5 is time and he takes over
and these death timers are massive the
wave they have in the bottom sight you
might be able to end this cheering and
there you have it those were our picks
for the top 10 best played by double it
do you agree or disagree with our list
we want to hear in the comments below
thanks for watching if you want more
great content be sure to hit that
subscribe button